today on the matt walsh show crazed lgbt
activists at a texas university go
insane shouting screaming stomping and
spitting because a campus speaker said
that we shouldn't castrate little boys
this is the state of the university
system in our country we'll talk about
it and play some of the footage which
you have to see as well also ron
desantis provokes widespread media
condemnation because he told some kids
they don't have to wear a mask he's
right of course as usual plus a handful
of republicans refuse to sign a
congressional resolution in support of
ukraine we'll look at their reasoning
and you can decide if they were right or
wrong and ukraine has found a way to
deal with looters it's a strategy that i
think we should probably think of
adopting in our daily cancellation a
hollywood icon is in trouble with the
mob because he didn't like hollywood's
latest gay western we'll talk about that
and much more today on the matt wall
show
[Applause]
[Music]
dealing with finances is just not an
enjoyable experience no matter what but
what i can say is that when i see my
expenses decrease and my savings
increase that is an enjoyable and
rewarding experience unto itself i've
been saving hundreds of a month thanks
to american financing who helped me
refinance my mortgage i've been able to
put more money away towards family
vacations and other financial goals that
we have with interest rates being so low
it would be a mistake to not at least
give them a call and check this out let
american financing help you so that you
can have more fun and you can enjoy your
life a little bit more by saving money
you can take advantage of a free
mortgage review where a salary based
mortgage consultant will help guide you
through all the different refinancing
options available to you there's no
pressure it's no obligation just a
simple conversation about custom loans
that will help you achieve your goals
faster if you start soon you could skip
up to two payments and you may close in
as fast as 10 days if you want to get
this savings and get it fast all you
have to do is call 866 569-4711 that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
to refinancing your home today american
financing nmls 182 334 and mls
consumeraccess.org
jeff younger is a business owner in
texas and now a candidate running for
the texas house of representatives you
may recognize his name if you follow a
select few conservative media outlets
anyway because he's been locked in a
years-long custody battle with his wife
ann georgelis
now the center of this dispute is their
now nine-year-old son james anne says
that james is really a girl and uh and
she wants to transition him you know she
found out that james really has a girl
magically trapped inside him and so she
wants to uh do the transition in fact
she has long since begun the so-called
social transition dressing him in girl's
clothes
giving him a girl's name luna
now jeff fiercely opposes this plan as
any sane and loving parent would and has
been fighting for custody so that he can
prevent the further psychological and
physical abuse of his boy
ultimately jeff lost the fight
tragically and the courts handed custody
over to mommy munchausen so jeff is now
running for office because he realizes
that the only way to save his son now is
to see to it that childhood gender
transitions are legally outlawed
completely
now to that end
as we talked about last week texas has
gone part of the way
the governor recently declared that the
medical transition of minors is child
abuse under state law under already
existing state law and any adult
participating in or facilitating the
practice should be arrested and charged
that's that's a good step it's an
important step
but as long as this barbarity is not
officially and specifically outlawed it
will still happen
the governor can only do so much on his
own the aclu is sued to block abbott's
directive from going into effect because
of course the aclu cares deeply about
protecting the right of adults to
butcher drug and castrate children what
this means most likely is that the whole
matter will be tied up in the courts for
the foreseeable future um the texas
legislature has to act and that's what
jeff younger is calling for and that's
why he is running for office and it's
also why he held an event at the
university of north texas last night to
discuss this issue and explain why in
his view
child transition should be criminalized
now the event drew controversy from the
moment it was announced
and uh when flyers started going up
around the campus last week
uh last week the president of the
university neil smatresk
responded to complaints over the flyers
by condemning them the flyers not the
complaints as intolerant
in a campus-wide email he said quote i
know the last several days may have felt
particularly difficult for the
transgender members of our community due
to the intolerant views of a handful of
campus members we have a variety of
resources through our division of
inclusion diversity equity and access to
support you during your time at unt and
we hope to offer you a safe place to
heal and grow your support system
so
the president university after scooping
the lgbt complainers up in his arms
patting them on the back swaddling them
assuring them that everything will be
okay the poor babies he did finally
affirm though the right of jeff younger
to come and say his peace
but he also accused younger of quote
challenging the very existence of trans
people
so the stage was set the irrational
beliefs and attitudes of the radical
lgbt leftist leftists had been affirmed
and legitimized
and that led directly to what happened
last night
younger
came to give his talk as scheduled
and all hell broke broke loose in quite
a literal sense in fact
as many of the protesters appeared to be
demonically possessed outside of the
event an enormous pitchfork mob
assembled demanding that the event be
shut down we have some of that footage
let's watch that
it's a paper on the ground officer i
understand that there is the free speech
portion
[Music]
you guys are all
okay so you see a pretty good crowd
there
but they didn't settle for remaining
outside
if they had just done that then you know
whatever but they flooded into the room
and shut the event down themselves
inside preventing younger from
presenting his case
and they did that by chanting and
screaming at him the entire time listen
to this
you could practically smell that room
from here
truly a collection of the greasiest and
foulest ugliest humans you're likely to
ever come across
and they weren't satisfied to keep their
tantrum purely verbal at one point in
response to younger misgendering someone
in the audience i.e gendering them
accurately
somebody stood up on the desk and spat
on him
she didn't grab my watch
she
she
hey
i just hope jeff got his rabies shot
that's all i can say
now
when i watch all this unfold
a few things come immediately to mind
first of all
um modern college leftists are
apparently going to barbers who use weed
whackers and chainsaws they go to like
the landscaper to get their hair cut
the worst haircuts i've ever seen all in
one room
more importantly um i may have to pay a
visit to this school you know bullies
like this should not get what they want
what they want is to make sure that
nobody who opposes them ever shows up on
their campus again they're trying to
send a message
what they ought to get instead then is
you know me
if you're affiliated with the
conservative group on campus there
please reach out to me maybe we can set
something up
most importantly of all though i think
our three points
now first of all to echo something that
our very own god king jeremy boring
posted this morning in response to this
you are a fool
if you pay to send your kids to college
you are paying paying exorbitant
back-breaking sums
to have your children turned into that
you're paying to have them brainwashed
you are sending them into the most
expensive cult commune in history where
their mind and soul will be eaten and
inside the shell that was once your
child will be placed a blue-haired
lunatic beholden to a worldview so
irrational and fragile that he'll melt
into a puddle if somebody even so much
as mentions in his presence that men
have penises and women have vaginas you
are paying for that
you are asking for that to happen
you are going into debt to make that
happen to your kid
now sure there are some exceptions
there are a few good schools left in the
country a few
and there are plenty of kids who go into
these environments and they come out
with their minds and souls somehow still
intact i meet students like that all the
time at my events
but the odds are stacked against them
and most
are destroyed by the experience it's
just not worth the risk
it's not close to worth it
it's definitely not worth paying a
hundred thousand dollars for
two notice that when i outline the
horrors of the modern university system
i do not say that the kids who graduate
from these institutions can't get jobs
that's not one of the things that i list
now it's true that a lot of them indeed
cannot get jobs but we make a mistake
when we point to all the tantripping
tantruming
gender studies majors in that room and
scoff and just assure ourselves that
well the real world will catch up with
them
they're going to be unemployed living in
their mom's basements rejected by
society
certainly that will be the case for some
of them certainly it should be the case
for all of them
but it's not the case for all of them
not even most of them
the scary thing is that in fact they do
get jobs
the real world will not catch up with
them
i hate to say it
they are going out and redefining the
real world
we are living in a culture and a country
increasingly shaped by people like that
those kids in that room
that's your next generation of teachers
those are university professors
those are human resource managers
at fortune 500 companies
those are diversity consultants
they'll take their blue hair over to a
nearby middle school and help to keep
this self-perpetuating cycle of crazy
going
in other words those kids become this
lady
let's talk about gender roles and
talking about them in the classroom so
this last week as you all know was
valentine's day and this is what my
students discussed through the week wow
it wasn't the first time they were
talking about the gender binary we
already talked about pronouns we had
talked about girl and voice stereotypes
we had named those stereotypes talking
about access we've been talking about
trans rights recently we've been having
discussions about power and dynamics of
power in our society which leads right
into social norms which leads right into
the gender binary our discussions were
amazing y'all this is my thing out of
those discussions we ended up moving
into self-love because i realized so
many of my students were already looking
at themselves and at their bodies and
even at their gender negatively this to
say that the gender binary is constantly
harming us day to day only a few people
gain power from it everyone else is
trying to conform to the societal norms
this harm as we're already seeing starts
at a young age
uh i like to clarify i said lady i'm not
exactly exactly sure about that actually
um now that person
ought to be unemployed clearly but isn't
that person is teaching your kids
one more point um if it wasn't already
clear to you
hopefully that video
well that video we just played and
especially the clips at the university
wakes you up to the fact that there is
no soft soft pedaling you know there's
no diplomatic nice or polite way to
engage with these people
what they need are bullies
they obviously were not bullied nearly
enough in grade school
maybe if somebody had punched them in
the mouth in seventh grade some of this
could have been avoided but instead
they've been coddled their entire lives
while also being brainwashed
the only way to stand up to this and to
respond to it
is to be an even bigger bully than they
are
so if you're on the side of truth of
biology of protecting children from
being butchered castrated and poisoned
you know of basic moral decency then you
should project unwavering confidence and
strength
they're all in that room
screaming hysterically because jeff
younger doesn't want to have his son
castrated
okay they spit on him because he doesn't
want to have his son castrated
they're posit they are so upset about
that
that they they want this guy dead they
hate him
because he doesn't want to have his son
castrated
their position their world view is the
most twisted evil insane thing
any of us have ever come across in our
lifetimes
that's how bad it is
that's how it should be treated
with contempt
and derision
if somebody is arguing for the right of
plastic surgeons to amputate a healthy
14 year old girl's breasts
and you're treating that argument with
even a modicum of respect
you already lost
now remember something
when we engage with the crazies we're
not just engaging with the crazies or
even primarily
we're really trying to reach all of the
basically sane people who are on the
verge of getting caught up in this
madness
you know they may lack the philosophical
grounding the mental toughness the
courage whatever else to withstand the
tidal wave a tidal wave of insanity that
pummels them constantly
there's a lot of people in that category
and our first job and our
foremost job is to send a message to
them
that it's okay to be sane it's okay to
be normal
and and you don't do that by lending
validity to insanity
i think what our country needs now
desperately needs is the truth told
directly and loudly and without apology
that's our only hope
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know finding great employees in
today's world isn't the easiest thing to
do i've had so many listeners right into
my show telling me how hard it is to get
quality employees to show up for an
interview and even when they hire a lot
of their candidates don't even show up
for the job
so if you're struggling to find quality
candidates for your job opening i highly
recommend checking out ziprecruiter
ziprecruiter uses a powerful matching
technology to match candidates with the
right experience to the position that
you need filled fast you can easily
review these recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job so you're going out proactively
and finding the people that you need and
that's going to encourage them to apply
faster zippered recruiters technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
if you use zip recruiter you can even
find candidates that are as hard working
and dedicated as uh
my producers who help me make great
content daily and who also write the
copy for these commercials as you can
tell so try zip recruiter today and find
great and dedicated employees today you
can try they're powerful technology for
yourself for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com walsh that
ziprecruiter.com walsh to find your new
favorite employee today
all right so um
by the way this will give you an idea of
just how boring i am a couple days ago i
was talking to my daughter about lent
and she was telling me what she was
giving up for lent which i think she
said candy so we'll see about that but
then she asked me what i was giving up
and i said at the time i still hadn't
decided yet i was trying to decide and
she said
i know what you can give up daddy uh you
you could give up buying socks you love
buying socks
and this is how my kids see me
um
and as i as i head into middle age
this is how i'm seen my greatest passion
in life in their eyes
the thing that they define me by
is that i like to buy socks
and you know the even sadder thing
is that she's right and also i realize
that i i can't
give that up because it'd be too hard
that's a cross i can't bear i mean i'd
have to cancel my monthly sock
subscription first of all because i do
have a monthly sock subscription
i can't do that
and the idea of just wearing old socks
for a month and a half is just
horrifying to me
let this cup pass for me i the sacrifice
is too hard too great
um okay the
something interesting happened last
night the media briefly moved away from
ukraine because they had bigger fish to
fry and that would be ron desantis
apparently they say ron desantis was uh
was mean to somebody um about masks god
forbid
he uh he bullied some students
because they were wearing masks that's
that's the claim anyway you know he was
speaking out of school and uh they were
standing behind the podium in masks and
he bullied them
that's that's how it's being reported
and it's big news
i mean this for for a moment anyway this
even knocked ukraine out of the out of
the the top of the news
cycle but that's the way it's being
reported let's watch the actual footage
and uh you can decide for yourself let's
see it
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take it off honestly it's
not doing anything and we got to stop
with this theater so you want to wear it
fine but this is this is ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf
uh yeah i don't know i i listen to that
and what i heard maybe i'm hallucinating
but i'm pretty sure i heard him say
if you want to wear it fine
so the way that this is being reported
is that he forced the kids to say you
can't wear the mask he ripped it off
their faces and lit it on fire right in
front of them
now i would have liked it even more if
he had done that but he didn't he
actually said it's fine if you want to
wear it but you don't have to
um
and he was exactly right to do that
he was exactly right
and we'll talk more about why he was
right in his uh in the way he approached
this in a second but before we get there
so as i said the media latched on to
this
and uh before you know it
we had the local nbc affiliate they were
outside of this event and they were
pulling parents aside the parents of the
poor victims the children who were told
they didn't have to wear masks
they were pulling the parents aside the
parents were lining up
to you know use this to get some
attention and to make themselves the
victim to make their kids the victim but
primarily themselves and so here's one
mother and you'll notice uh
there's a
certain disparity here it's not exactly
symmetrical because you'll notice a
mother and one of the kids standing here
and the kid's wearing a mask
the mother is not
not wearing a mask and yet she's very
very upset that her son was told that he
didn't have to wear one let's watch this
i'm responsible for him
and i told him to wear that mask
and governor desantis and he's looking
at this adult authority and telling him
oh you didn't have to wear the mask what
was your reaction when you heard the
governor tell you and your classmates
remove your masks
um a bit of surprise and shock more of
okay this
authority i thought this authority
figure is asking me to do something
that i know is probably going to end up
being controversial i took mine off
did you feel pressured by the governor
to do that um
um
a little it was more of a pressure of an
adult figure
asking me to do something and it's just
like all right why not it's just
shocking that the governor
told these kids
take off your mask he pretty much said
take off your masses stupid and take off
your mask your parents don't matter even
though i'm i'm telling you parents
matter
and he's telling my minor child to take
off his mask he's putting us at risk
so oh yeah i was upset very upset
putting you at risk huh what a terrible
mother this this woman is she's just a
terrible person and mother terrible
putting you you're parading your kid up
there as some kind of political prop so
you can get attention
claiming she's he's putting us at risk
you're not even wearing a mask yourself
you're the one who is if anyone is most
at risk of cove it's you you're older
you appear to be uh you know overweight
and so that puts you in a higher risk
category
your kids had almost no risk at all you
got him wearing a mask
he's the governor's putting us at risk
she says without a mask on
but that's just a great uh what a what a
i could not have scripted it any better
if i wanted to demonstrate and
illustrate the insanity of the way that
we've approached kovan especially as as
as it pertains to kids i couldn't have
scripted it any better
because she's not wearing a mask while
she screams about how it's we're putting
be put at risk
he's wearing a mask
and on top of it she's using all these
words like it was shocking and
horrifying my kid was traumatized and
then you go over to the kid
and he says you know
did you feel pressure um
a little but yeah he didn't care
at all you could see in the video that
kid is one of the ones you see in the
video take the mask and he smiles when
he takes it off he's happy to have the
thing off his face
he's only wearing it because his mom is
forcing him to speaking of munch housing
by proxy we've got other another
munchausen mommy here
the only reason he's wearing it he was
he was thanking god
that he uh could take it off
and you notice what he said it was
actually it was actually very
interesting
he said that um
he was hesitant to take it off
not because he thought that he would die
if he took it off or or that it was uh
unsafe
he said that it would be controversial
to take it off that was his
reason you know um so this kid is not
stupid
unlike a lot of those kids we saw in the
video at the texas university very
stupid this this kid isn't
so he he it's pretty clear from what he
said he knows that he's not at any great
risk here but it's controversial just in
the sense of the way people will react
to it and he knows and what he didn't
say but you could kind of fill in the
blanks because you see his mom there
it's it's controversial for him at home
if he takes the mask off
i mean there's only two ways of looking
at this with that mom
either
she knows that the mask
um
is not necessary
and forces him to wear it anyway
just as a virtue signal using her kit as
a prop or
she thinks the mask is necessary
for her own safety
but she doesn't want to make the
sacrifice of wearing it because it's
uncomfortable and all of that and so she
forces him to do it for her
either way no matter how you slice it
this is a terrible mom
i think we got another video of a parent
complaining let's uh this one at least
is wearing a mask for uh he's putting in
the effort to put on a show here he puts
the mask on and here's what this parrot
says
i would tell them to stop bullying kids
it's fine if you don't want to wear a
mask but encourage others to do what
they feel is safe
and and leave it at that i was just
thinking i don't if i could take it off
or leave it on because the governor he
has to take it off
but i thought about it and it's my right
to have my mask on
his mother tells him to wear the mask i
tell him it's his choice so he made that
choice and the governor has no right to
tell no kid or no one
who they can or can't wear a mask he
doesn't have that right
he didn't tell him they can't he didn't
say that
i mean am i am i losing my mind
again am i hallucinating
he didn't say you have to take it off
but there's another kid who doesn't care
it doesn't care about this
but uh his parents are forcing him to
pretend that he cares
you know next there's gonna be the
lawsuit or something
we're gonna get uh who's that that the
lawyer um who repels down you know
after any kind of politician ben crump
ben crump's gonna be on the scene i
guarantee you that guy's gonna be there
and there's gonna be some kind of a
lawsuit or something
that's what's happening next
but
ron desantis um he was exactly right to
to do what he did
and i would even say i would encourage
anybody out there um
this is so we should we should all take
ron desantis lead and uh and do the same
thing um
if you see
a child wearing a mask
you should go up to that child and say
you don't need to wear that there's no
reason for you to be wearing that
your parents are maybe forcing you to
wear that they shouldn't they're wrong
because all of these kids are victims of
munchausen by proxy they're they are
victims of abuse
and uh what they need is some sane adult
to tell them that no this the air is not
toxic you're not gonna die if you take
it off people are not toxic it's okay to
show your face
not only okay you should
you know you have a right to show your
face you have a right to see other
people's faces
none of the adults around you are
wearing them you can take that off and
you'll be fine
so you should say that to every kid you
see wearing a mask absolutely for their
sake
because they're being abused
um
and as for adults who still wear masks
you should just point at them and laugh
and mock them mercilessly
because that's what they deserve
you know
you see an adult wearing a mask you
paranoid freaks
you look ridiculous in the mask you
idiots that's the appropriate response
to adults but the kids who again are
being abused and being forced into this
um that's not what you should say you
should you should respond just like
ronnie santos did
i thought there was a lot of uh
generosity of heart and spirit in the
way that ronnie sanders went about that
because he's concerned for those kids
and the way they're being abused
all right um
let's go to this
from pbs says the u.s house has
overwhelmingly approved a resolution
steadfastly staunchly proudly and
fervently in support of ukraine
lawmakers said wednesday that history
was watching the way the world responds
as ukrainians fight to save their
western-south-style democracy from
invasion by russia with intensifying
urgency many in congress said more must
be done to help ukraine and cut off
russian president vladimir putin's
ability to wage war
uh in the senate lindsey graham was also
introducing a resolution that would back
ukraine's claim international court that
putin and his cronies have committed war
crimes
and so they all signed this resolution
um or almost all of them did and this is
a day after
uh many of them republicans and
democrats as tucker carlson pointed out
in his monologue last night which was
excellent you know republicans and
democrats showed up to the state of the
union with their you know draped
basically in ukrainian flags with their
ukrainian lapels and you know all
different kinds of
ukrainian
apparel um
and accessories
but what you notice
is that many of them actually took off
their american flag lapels and put the
ukrainian flag on
now there were some of these congress
members who had both
um but many of them again including
plenty of republicans they had they were
not wearing any american flag at all
they took it off to put the ukrainian
flag on instead
this is something
you will not see
in any non-western country
okay you go outside of the west
and you you free yourself from this from
this unique particular sickness
that that many people in this country
suffer from
where they think that that uh you know
patriotism
for our country is wrong but we could be
patriotic for other people's countries
go outside of that you're not going to
find
you know
politicians of other countries taking
their own country's flag off and and
wearing another country's flag
so after that bit of virtue signaling
they put this um
this
declaration together and they came out
in support of ukraine now a few
republicans did not sign there were
three republicans who said i'm not going
to sign it
one of them was thomas massey
and thomas massey is you hear me mention
i'm kind of frequently on the show
because he's one of the good ones in in
congress among republicans one of the
only good ones
um and he's intelligent and also has
moral and intellectual courage and that
is in very short supply among our
leaders and so he didn't sign it
is it because he supports putin
he's a he's a stooge of putin he's a
he's a secret russian agent sent here by
putin is it that or does he have
reasons intelligent reasons to not sign
something like this
you don't have to agree with those
reasons by the way but i'll read he put
a twitter thread out there where he
explained his reasons
you don't have to agree with them
but if you after i read this to you
if your takeaway is that he's a stooge
of putin then you're just a very stupid
person and it's not worth talking to you
because whether you agree or disagree
you have to at least admit if you're an
intelligent rational person
that his reasoning is reasonable
so here's what he says
i fully support the right of the people
of ukraine to self-determination however
there are many reasons i could not vote
for the seven page resolution that
passed the house of representatives
today
the resolution contains an open-ended
call for additional and immediate
defensive security assistance this term
is so broad that it could invite that it
could include american boots on the
ground or as some of my colleagues have
already requested us and for enforcement
of a no-fly zone
it expands the geographic scope of the
u.s commitment to the conflict in
ukraine by condemning the country of
belarus we should not be seeking to name
new enemies or committing to overturning
other governments
it calls for fully isolating russia
economically
this would hurt low-income u.s citizens
who are already reeling from inflation
innocent people in russia many of whom
oppose putin's aggression would suffer
under crippling sanctions possibly
turning them against us crippling
sanctions could also drive putin to
become more desperate inciting him to
resort to drastic measures such as
escalating the weapons employed or the
people targeted the resolution contains
a gratuitous statement that ukraine and
nato will determine the relationship
between the two of them of course this
is true but why should congress assert
this now when the goal is to de-escalate
the conflict
and finally it calls for continuing
support for
for continuing support as long as the
russian federation continues to violate
ukraine's sovereignty depending on the
definition of violate this could be a
u.s commitment to forever be actively
engaged in a conflict with another
nuclear country
those are his reasons
uh sounds perfectly rational to me
and i happen to agree with them
and again i'm not saying that uh that
every person who hears it has to agree
with it
uh maybe you could nitpick here and
there
but
at least what tommy thomas massey did is
he read the resolution
which is a step that i guarantee you
most of these people didn't even do
so he actually read the language and he
thought about
what does this mean do i actually
support
everything in this and and what about
the implications
i mean he knew that the political
calculation is because of all the war
fever and everything right now
and all in the propaganda and people are
kind of um
caught up in in it
the smartest thing politically is just
to sign the damn thing
but instead he thought well what does it
actually say what are the implications
do i really support it yes i support
recurring defending itself obviously no
i'm not a fan of of putin obviously but
do i support everything all the language
in this particular resolution and he
said no
agree a disagree you gotta at least
respect that
i mean any time a politician
even if i don't agree with them
anytime a politician is willing to take
some kind of stand
that's going to be politically unpopular
but because they're trying to
you know
do what they actually think is the right
thing to do
i'm always going to be impressed with
that
i'm also impressed with this um
meanwhile over in ukraine this is
reported by the blaze ukrainian citizens
have allegedly taken to publicly shaming
those who decide to take advantage of
the war-caused chaos to do a bit of
looting according to ukraine's
correspondent
one enterprising citizen who decided to
take advantage of an understaffed store
chose to buy something there without
money the looter was unlucky he was seen
by local residents they called the
police to the place
the arriving patrol found the marauder
without pants and taped to a pole
so
okay here's the guy that's that's the
looter
i guess other citizens saw this guy
looting
and so they taped him to a pole
and they pulled his pants out and taped
him to a pole just kind of like public
shaming thing this is also sort of the
spider-man
strategy of uh you know you don't have
the you don't have the the webs the
indestructible webs but he kind of you
know
ties him to a pole let the police show
up so that's what the ukrainians did
here i think there are other do we have
other uh
photos as well
okay there's another guy taped to a poll
public shaming he's got a sign on i
assume that says looter or something
like that
um
and then here's these guys okay these
guys were stripped naked and they had i
assume something like looter written
across their bodies blindfolded
and paraded through the street
by concerned citizens
more people those people are tied to
pulse with their pants down
so now for me look this is this is still
a little bit too lenient for me
um i would like it if i you know maybe
and i understand that the resources and
everything are not
maybe don't allow for this but in an
ideal world you would do this and then
you would also have a supply of like
tomatoes and rotten eggs which again you
know war-torn country they're not going
to have that but if we were to adopt
this here then you know you tied to a
poll put the sign on them looter and
then you have um
you know crates of rotten uh uh eggs and
tomatoes and things and people can come
by just have fun throwing them and you
keep them you keep them attached to that
pole for you know a day two days or so
i think that's a great strategy
um
i really appreciate that
so well done ukraine
imagine if we were to
adopt something like that in san
francisco
maybe not san francisco now i think you
know the problem is in san francisco if
you make them march through the street
naked they might like it too much
so
some kind of public shaming mechanism
is the appropriate response
and a lot of times that could be even uh
better than
yeah you could if you could send them to
prison that's also good
but public shaming is um
is is a real tool that societies have in
their belt
that these days we don't use anymore
because we have this idea that you
should never shame anyone it's always
bad to make people feel ashamed
well no
actually the equation is pretty simple
you should not shame people
for doing things that are not shameful
okay and this is what we get wrong this
is what canceled culture gets wrong
much of the time is that people are
getting shamed for doing things that
aren't shameful or shame for doing
things that don't really matter
you know um
but if someone is doing something that
is shameful like looting is a shameful
activity
to do it while your country is under
siege
and people are dying and you're taking
advantage of that
that's shameful
in some ways it's even more shameful
because at least in that case you can
claim that you were desperate you had no
choice i don't buy it but you could
claim that
it's even more shameful to do it in our
country
but we're not under any official
military siege
and you're taking advantage of the fact
that the police aren't enforcing the law
and you are victimizing
and exploiting your fellow community
members the people who run these shops
these are these aren't millionaires
living on uh in mansions
50 miles away these are people in your
community that you're victimizing
and yes you should be ashamed for that
it's a good tool that we should be using
more often let's get down to the comment
section
[Music]
[Music]
let's see steve jobs
says yes matt i'm an african and yes we
still have common sense in this part of
the world
we still can distinguish between man and
woman without any difficulty
we still believe in the existence of
absolutes i personally think that the
west has lost its mind
well that's good to hear but you might
want to
you might want to keep it down a little
bit because
the more that you point this out the
more that the ideological colonizers
um among the left here in the west are
going to say well we got to get down to
africa and change that oh they still
believe in men and women down there we
got to change that
and of course i'm being facetious
because the leftists already know that
and this project of ideological
colonization is well underway in africa
and all across the world
it's just that they run into
they run into problems because you know
when you go to other parts of the world
and you're talking to people who have
not been brought up
in our culture
and don't at all have the same kind of
framework that we have and you go to
them and you say something like hey you
know that uh if a man feels like he's a
woman then he's really a woman that just
doesn't mean anything at all to them and
so you have a lot of there's a lot of
ground work that the left has to lay
in these other parts of the world and
they're trying to do it
and if they're not opposed
and opposed passionately then eventually
they'll succeed
um
cool papa j magic says matt i absolutely
understand your point about trans being
a white western thing specifically but
pointing out the hypocrisy of the regime
does nothing they don't mind being
hypocritical and or contradictory they
literally have no problem with it
uh yeah i agree with you i don't think
that just by pointing out hypocrisy
you're going to i don't think that when
someone's being a hypocrite
and you say you're being a hypocrite
they're gonna say oh you know you're
right uh never mind i changed my mind
that's not what's happening um
but there's still a value in pointing
out
intellectual inconsistencies logical
inconsistencies
and also again i go to what i said at
the start um
i'm not trying to primarily convince the
regime
you know i'm trying to reach all of the
same normal people out there who are
feeling bewildered and are caught up in
this storm and are beginning to lose
their sense of which way is up and which
way is down
those are the people that i think were
primarily tried to reach i did
accidentally skip right over the uh the
video comments
so because i'm i
i
i i feel very nervous about the video
comments now because mckenna has ruined
it for for all of us frankly but um okay
we'll play some videos dailywire.com
sweet baby comments let's start with um
this one's on the screen go ahead
[Music]
so that is that appears to be uh
okay it says right there on the screen
so my doc phil episode is being played
in some kind of school so look i like i
said not all schools are bad
certainly not all teachers are bad
um there are still some very good
teachers out there
and uh i i don't know i feel about the
good teachers the way that i feel about
cops
like the good cops i don't know i don't
know how you do it in this environment
but um we need people to do it i have a
lot of respect for that
and um that's great you know you should
play that episode it is educational
because it's also it's both sides of the
argument
being presented i i think that episode
should be played in every um
in every classroom in the country
um
because it's both sides of the argument
being presented and you can decide who
wins
all right i don't know why i'm going to
do this but let's go to clip 15. hey
matt long time listener here i look
forward to hearing your video comments
every episode and i have to say the one
that your producer mckenna picked out
last week
has to be one of my favorites but i
might be a little biased so i understand
i would like to start a new trend
akena's unite against matt's video
comment selection
this would be a beginning for life don't
give me the sweet baby gang for life
after that don't do that to me
i don't believe you first of all
i just don't believe it that you
actually thought that was this is a
this is a coordinated assault against me
this is what i get
i try to bring other voices into this
show so it's not just me rambling the
whole time
and and i end up with this with this
conspiracy
it's outrageous
uh but there's some good news scott says
matt please shave your beard for a 900th
episode special no that's not happening
and of course you're banned for even
suggesting that but it is indeed the
900th episode and i would be remiss for
not mentioning we've done 900 of these
things and i thought you know for real
this time this this is this is real okay
to honor the occasion
and i know i've i've joked about this
before and all of that it's been kind of
anticlimactic but to honor this occasion
because it's 900 episodes we've done
that's a big deal um and so many of you
have stuck stuck with us for for
so many have stuck with us through all
900 episodes i don't know why but you
have and so to honor that and to honor
you i thought i would actually play the
banjo for real this time
absolutely for real it's here in the
studio with me
and um so let me go get it
oh i can't i forgot
yeah that's a sheet it's fake i don't
have a real studio so
i wanted to
i wanted to but unfortunately the banjo
does no longer exists it is now just a
picture on a sheet which is hanging
behind me
still 900 episodes that's a big deal
isn't it well if you thought the daily
wire was going to take a break from
bringing you new awesome content think
again we're adding new content on what
seems like a weekly basis and we're so
excited to share our latest edition with
you so get ready for march 10th that's
the premiere of our latest film the
hyperions it doesn't follow the same old
hollywood prescribed formula it's a film
that stands entirely on its own and it's
a totally unique thing you can see that
in the trailer check it out here good
day hyperion club members
[Music]
[Applause]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
so the hyperians is a throwback
superhero meets dysfunctional family
meets quirky criminals and it's 100
worth the stream we'll be streaming the
film once on march 10th for all to see
on youtube but after that you've got to
be a member to get in on the action so
head to dailywire.com subscribe so you
don't miss any more of the growing uh
cache of content that we have to offer
also it's um
no secret that wokeness has infiltrated
nearly everything we used to enjoy
including sports especially sports
really and we aren't the only ones who
are fed up that's why orlando magic
player jonathan isaac is publishing a
book the daily wire about the rise of
his basketball career his journey into
faith and his strength to stand alone in
the face of immense social pressure this
autobiographical
autobiographical there we go account
will give insight and inspiration to
anyone looking to take the woke out of
sports and also anyone just looking for
inspiration to you know stand and uh and
speak the truth the book is available
for pre-order now at amazon so reserve
your copy today and finally as everyone
knows by now the daily wire is rapidly
expanding into entertainment and with
that expansion we're searching for a
council of business and legal affairs to
join our legal team in nashville as our
in-house legal expert on the film and
television industry
the council of business and legal
affairs will manage all legal aspects of
the daily wires entertainment content
including development acquisition
production and finance as well as
production legal and intellectual
property work for all of the daily wire
shows we need someone with eight plus
years of experience in the film and
television industry this is a perfect
opportunity for an entertainment lawyer
who's ready to get out of hollywood's
woke groupthink cycle and find new
opportunities so to apply for this and
to view a full list of our current
openings
including mckenna's job which will be
opening up soon at daily wire please
visit dailywire.com careers now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so this segment is not always a time for
attacking demeaning and insulting people
um
well i guess it is and really the whole
show is that but
sometimes i do it in the context of
defending someone and that would be the
case today sam elliot is a hollywood
film legend or as he's known to most
people the guy with the mustache and the
deep voice he's being cancelled by the
left-wing mob for some negative comments
he made about a recent and critically
acclaimed western called power of the
dog
now elliott did not like the movie he
thought it was an insult to the western
genre
but before we analyze his criticisms um
of the film i think we have to
acknowledge sort of the elephant on the
ranch here elliott is a veteran of the
western genre and an expert on the
subject he's also the star of 1883 a
western tv series that just wrapped up
its first season
but you could accuse elliot perhaps of
of throwing stones in a glass saloon and
i'm going to keep with the western puns
and nobody can stop me sorry
because 1883 is itself as i mentioned on
the show before
an insult to the western genre and the
show starts strong sam elliott plays an
old hard-bitten civil war general who
agrees to usher a group of hapless
foreigners through the wilderness to the
west coast
a perfect setup for a series how could
anyone find a way to botch it well botch
it they did within a few episodes the
show had devolved into a woke teenage
soap opera all of the interesting
characters were relegated to the
background as a the plot increasingly
revolved around a teenage girl pursuing
her pursuing her various love interests
across the great plains of course all
the bad guys the group encounter are
white
and when they finally run across some
comanches the infamously brutal warriors
were friendly and became their saviors
and
rescued them from one jam after another
teenage girl promptly fell in love with
one of them like 30 minutes after her
fiance had just been murdered by the way
and in the ultimate jump the shark
moment
she and her comanche lover kissed each
other passionately while a tornado went
right over top them meanwhile of course
in true woke fashion every woman in this
version of the west is an independent
fierce gun-toting badass even girls who
had never held a gun before are still
able to take down bad guys with one shot
while riding horseback with you know the
reins between their teeth perhaps worst
of all sam elliott's character
devolved into a whiny wimp constantly
crying about everything
he was crying in the very first scene
because his whole family had just died
of smallpox
now i will allow an emotional display in
that case if your whole family dies of
smallpox
i'll put that on the list of approved
reasons for a man to cry
i mean i'll give you like 10 minutes
then you got to wrap it up but
then he keeps crying throughout the
entire thing
i was waiting for a scene where elliot's
character would break down in tears in
the midst of an intense fire fight only
to have a 13 year old female gunslinger
come and save him you know carry him out
carry him out of danger cradling him
like a baby
i stopped watching the show in the
middle so perhaps that scene did
eventually happen i also stopped
watching before they introduced a
genderqueer pansexual cowgirl character
cow them character i guess but i'm
assuming that happened as well all of
that to say
elliott shares some guilt when it comes
to the destruction and feminization of
the western genre yet that does not make
his criticisms illegitimate as for those
criticisms sam elliott is in a lot of
trouble with the peanut gallery because
he felt that power of the dog was as he
put it eloquently a piece of
an artsy progressive boring attempt to
deconstruct the traditional western
genre now i can tell you that i tried to
watch this movie myself before i really
knew what it was about
because i'll automatically watch
anything built as a western
and i fell asleep 15 minutes in so for
all of its other faults it was in
addition to being a piece of incredibly
dull and boring
it's also massively critically acclaimed
which shows why nobody cares what
critics think anymore in fact a quick
snapshot of some of those reviews can i
think give you an idea of what this
movie is all about
i just wish i'd read some of these
before i wasted 15 minutes of my life on
it but reading some of the summaries
compiled by rotten tomatoes
it says the power of the dog is a long
delayed contemplation on masculinity
from the female eye both about
repression and control
and then
benedict cumberbatch is extraordinary in
this subversive and spellbinding western
exploring masculinity and its oppressive
impact on society
and
can't campion the director weaves the
erotic the gothic and closeted
homosexuality together into a beautiful
yet tragic mosaic about internal gay
struggles
i actually sat down to watch that movie
uh un unbeknownst so there you go it is
a western which seeks to
deconstruct the genre by offering a
subversive psychodrama about closeted
homosexuality and toxic masculinity i
think that gives some context to
elliot's criticism which you can hear
here
there was a full-page ad out in the la
times
and there was a
a review
not a review but a club a clip yeah yeah
and it talked about the uh evisceration
of the american myth
huh
and i thought
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what is that this is the
guy that's done westerns forever for his
whole life the evisceration of american
whiffs i mean they made it look like
what are those what are all those
dancers those guys
in new york that wear bow ties and not
much else
remember them for back in the day oh the
chippendales yeah yeah that's what all
these cowboys in that movie looked like
uh-huh they're all running around in
shops and no shirts
there's all these illusions of
homosexuality
throughout the movie yeah
i think that's what the movie's about
yeah well what does this woman from who
jane campion yeah
she's a brilliant director yeah i love
her work right previous work sure but
what the [ __ ] does this woman from
down there come oh new zealand new
zealand right
know about
the american west and why did she shoot
this movie in new zealand and call it
montana
now leaving aside the fact that sam
elliott seasons all of his sentences
with a sprinkling of 14 f-bombs his
basic point is perfectly valid
and he's been condemned as homophobic
and bigoted and close-minded and all the
rest but it's a valid point first and
foremost
because it's his opinion which he was
asked for
this is the game we play in our society
now somebody has asked their opinion
about a given topic and they give their
opinion honestly and they're condemned
because it wasn't the right opinion
you know if you don't if you don't want
to hear someone's actual opinion don't
ask for it
elliott was asked unprompted if he'd
seen this film and what he thought of it
was it his moral obligation to lie or
was it his moral obligation to simply
have a different opinion is he required
to like a homoerotic western about the
dangers of masculinity
yeah that's really the point for the
left isn't it if somebody makes a movie
with progressive themes
especially gay themes it is your
responsibility to enjoy the film and say
so when prompted
you can't even pretend to like it you
have to actually like it or the or
you're canceled
but that's not how opinions work
you know it may surprise folks on the
left to hear this but not everybody
wants to see traditions deconstructed
all the time almost every western these
days is a deconstruction of traditional
westerns all aspects really of
traditional american culture are
constantly being deconstructed in fact
this is so common that now you might say
that deconstruction is our culture our
anti-culture so that by deconstructing
culture you're now simply participating
in it so actually the most subversive
kind of western these days would be a
traditional one one where the good guy
beats the bad guy and saves the woman
a western celebrating masculinity rather
than eviscerating it would be truly
subversive and traditional
subversive because it's traditional
that's what sam elliott wants to see
that's what many of us want to see
there's nothing there's nothing shameful
about saying so final point elliot takes
issue with the fact that a foreign woman
is making a western
i mean what does she know about the
american west he asks
well you could point out that foreigners
have been making westerns for a long
time that's where we get spaghetti
westerns from
yet elliott
has a right to this complaint because
isn't this exactly the sort of complaint
people on the left always make about
films these days
they say that if you're white you know
you can't play a non-white character if
you're not in a particular group you
can't portray that group or make films
about them
because you can't relate to their lived
experience or whatever now i think this
is a stupid criticism which is i why i
also personally don't have a problem per
se with foreigners making movies about
the american west but most of the people
attacking elliot for this point of view
are in no position to attack him
he's only applying their representation
logic consistently he's making exactly
the same kind of point about this film
that they have made about so many others
they are just allergic to logical
consistency which is why they're lashing
out and it's why they not sam elliott
are today cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
john bickley here daily wire editor and
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire
on today's episode casualties rise as
ukrainians continue to resist russia's
invasion
the doj will prosecute fraud and covet
relief funds and how did americans
receive biden's state of the union
address
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire